виступаючий переді мною представник
монобільшості вчергове забувся що війна
розпочалася у лютому 14го року а не в
22-му як він вже вкотре проголошує у цій
залі і до пана резнікова зокрема був
міністр оборони воюючої держави Полторак
який втрапив зробити ефективні реформи
зміцнювати армію і забезпечувати її
належним чином але мені би хотілося
після такого красивого гладенького звіту
пана міністра запитатися А що він робив
112 днів перед вторгненням він уже був
міністром А я нагадаю 28 січня 22го року
з цієї ложі уряду він говорив що це не
вторгнення а паніка в нашій голові і
грошей на армію достатньо і блокував
виділення 50 млрдв гривень на потреби
збройних сил України 22 лютого 22го року
в ефірі телебачення пан резніков говорив
про відсутність ударного угрупування на
півночі зокрема з Білорусі забуваючи що
в цей жеж час у нас міністр оборони
Білорусі красиво був на навчаннях в
Україні тому я мушу сказати що оці всі
яйця по 17 куртки блокування постачання
виробництва Дронів і БПЛА це лише
квіточки із в порівнянні із злочинною
цинічною і наглою непідготовкою до
вторгнення коли по суті робилося
абсолютно усе щоб Україна не вистояла я
нагадаю що за це має нести не тільки
політичну відповідальність цей міністр і
вся його команда яка разом з ним
працювала його вигороджувала але це є
кримінальна відповідальність стаття 11
Кримінального Кодексу України про
злочинну недбалість і по корупційних
скандалах сьогодні президент Литви
заголосив що корупція зупиняє поставки
зброї в України Так розберіться з
розкраданнями в міністерстві оборони їх
забагатолосува